the company that brought you Google
Glass the Google self-driving car some
of the craziest science fiction things
that you can possibly imagine is focused
on Counting strawberries and here's why
for the last decade or so Google X has
been designed to sort of go for these uh
so-called moonshot projects
many of these things have not panned out
but there have been a few successes
what's happened over the years is that
googlex has gone to being much more
pedestrian but also real businesses and
I think that's where project mineral
comes in
[Music]
mineral is working on a project to
basically bring Robotics and machine
learning and computer vision but to the
world of agriculture
they're building these things called
Rovers which are semi-autonomous remote
controlled robots
when it drives over these crop rows it's
taking pictures and those pictures are
then being fed into these very
sophisticated machine learning
algorithms you know how many
strawberries does this plant have how
many leaves does it have how tall is it
what species is it and it's trying to
use that data to help farmers say you
know with some certainty which plants
are doing well and which ones aren't
so the end goal here it's one is to
create a business that that generates
Revenue where they are able to sell
machine learning and the robotics
expertise that they have to agriculture
companies
beyond that I think the goal is to do
farming better and and in particular to
help farmers do more with less and when
you talk to people at X
what they say is you know climate change
is increasingly a huge part of their
work and you can see that the the
possible impact here if farmers are able
to you know develop better plants that
can deal with Rising temperatures if
they're able to use less water less
fertilizer that could have a significant
climate impact and it could you know
allow us to live Better Lives
[Music]